in the Middle Ages the Polish port of
Gdansk was one of the richest cities in
the world today it's a popular tourist
destination the kubicki restaurant on
the old port has existed for almost a
hundred years the former dance hall is a
Gdansk institution last year it was
renovated and the menu updated dummy and
Mazeroski is the head chef he cooks
traditional cuisine but also likes to
experiment finally but there's some
problems it was all the shoulders rather
horny but in gdansk poland biggest port
people have always been very familiar
with ingredients and spices from other
countries such as saffron saffron
vanilla and cinnamon I'm Emma Davis
merchants brought them in from all over
the world windows template the magnetic
apocalypse movie goes so actually gdansk
regime has always been very modern long
dis new stadium opened only by the bull
movies wolf the city's market hall and
vegetable market are close by this is
where the chef buys many of his
ingredients he thinks it's important to
buy regional products
the fish comes in every morning fresh
from the Baltic Sea Mazeroski buys
herring for euromaxx ala carte he gets
his herbes from the fields just up fed
gdansk hopes and spices are an important
part of his recipes
the chef has also discovered a small
family-run bakery near the restaurant
bread is still made according to
traditional recipes and there are no
artificial additives so let you say
Google fellow the muscles right is a
very important part of polish cuisine we
eat it for breakfast lunch and dinner
that's why I wanted to have the best
Fred as a middle and good bread belongs
to today's recipe pairing Tata on polish
black bread dummy and Mazeroski cuts the
fish into small pieces and then prepares
a special marinade
shantou Pocoyo dismissal of Kafka's boo
Moreno Valley after we chop it finely we
marinate the hearing the marinade is a
mixture of vinegar onions cloves red
pepper salt and sugar I should go gene
but nothing ever stays in there for
about 12 hours Oba Koko syllable bagel
then dived sour pickles and onions are
added to the fish I says mayonnaise a
handful of dill and a small bunch of
chives or finely chopped
all the ingredients have to be mixed
well Apple is then grate it into the
mixture food though circles are formed
from the black bread with a ring mold
and a few drops of lemon juice go on to
the herring
toxicol mr. go-to Vanya the cake not be
gentle I cook very simply but of course
it shouldn't be boring things thats it
is it'll be anything goes I go I use
simple ingredients in a modern way
Donald is it there are dishes with
ingredients with special types of
mushrooms such as truffles where
customers immediately say wow one
another's well but it's much harder to
cook something interesting with simple
ingredients rustic sputnik oof annual
total be Brazilian dummy and Mazeroski
uses them all to place the herring Tata
onto the black bread and serves it with
fresh herbs this traditional but simple
summer dish from the Polish Baltic coast
is now ready to eat enjoy